Even brighter than the moon, moon, moon
Boom, boom, boom
Car rides to Malibu
Strawberry ice cream, one spoon for two
And trading jackets, laughing about how small it looks on you
Watching reruns of Glee, being annoying
Singing in harmony, I bet she's bragging
To all her friends, saying you're so unique
So when you're gonna tell her
That we did that too, she thinks it's special
But it's all reused, that was our place, I found it first
I made the jokes you tell to her when she's with you
Do you get déjà vu when she's with you?
Do you get déjà vu?
Do you call her?
I'm gonna say my name, cause let's be honest
I'm gonna sound the same, I'm not an actress
I hate to think that I was just your type
I bet what she knows, Billy Joe, cause you played her uptown
Girl, you're singing it together, girl, I bet you even tell her
You love her, in between the chorus and the verse
So when you're gonna tell her
That we did that too, she thinks it's special
But it's all reused, that was the show we talked about
Played you the song she's singing now when she's with you
Do you get déjà vu when she's with you?
Do you get déjà vu?
She got every ice cream in her living room
Donuts, no tea, didn't do what I do
And you're trading jackets like we used to do
Everything is all reused
Play her piano but she doesn't know
That I was the one who taught you, Billy Joe
A different girl now but there's nothing new
I know you get déjà vu
You would not believe your eyes
If ten million fireflies lit up the world as I fell asleep
Cause they fill the open air
And leave teardrops everywhere
You'd think me rude but I would just stand and stare
I'd like to make myself believe
That planet Earth turns slowly
It's hard to say that I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep
Cause everything is never as it seems
Cause I get a thousand hugs
From ten thousand lightning bugs
As they try to teach me how to dance
A fox trot above my head
A sock hop beneath my bed
A disco ball is just hanging by a thread
I'd like to make myself believe
That planet Earth turns slowly
It's hard to say that I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep
Cause everything is never as it seems
Leave my door open just to crack
Cause I feel like such an insomniac
Why do I tire of counting sheep?
When I'm far too tired to fall asleep
To ten million fireflies
I'm weird cause I hate goodbyes
I got misty eyes as they said farewell
But I'll know where several are
If my dreams get real bizarre
Cause I saved a few and I keep them in a jar
I'd like to make myself believe
That planet Earth turns slowly
It's hard to say that I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep
Cause everything is never as it seems
I'd like to make myself believe
That planet Earth turns slowly
It's hard to say that I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep
Cause everything is never as it seems
I'd like to make myself believe
That planet Earth turns slowly
It's hard to say that I'd rather stay awake when I'm asleep
Because my dreams are bursting at the seams
I've got sunshine on a cloudy day
When it's cold outside I've got the month of May
I guess you'd say
What can make me feel this way
My girl, my girl, my girl
Talking about my girl, my girl
I've got so much fun in the bee's endemic
I've got a sweeter song than the birds in the trees
Well I guess you'd say
What can make me feel this way
My girl, my girl, my girl
Talking about my girl, my girl
Yeah, yeah, yeah
I don't need no money
Watchin' my fame
I've got all the riches baby
One man can claim
Well I guess you'd say
What can make me feel this way
My girl, my girl, my girl
Talking about my girl, my girl
I've got sunshine on a cloudy day
I've even got the month of May
We go together
Better than birds of a feather, you and me
We change the weather, yeah
I'm getting heat in December when you pound me
I've been dancing on top of cars and stumbling out of bars
I follow you through the dark, can't get enough
You're the medicine and the pain, the tattoo inside my brain
And baby you know it's obvious
I'm a sucker for you
Said a word and I'll go anywhere blindly
I'm a sucker for you, yeah
Any road you take you know that you'll find me
I'm a sucker for all the subliminal things
No one knows about you, about you, about you, about you
And I'm making my typical me, make my typical move
I'm a sucker for you, yeah
Don't complicate it, yeah
Cause I know you and you know everything about me
I can't remember
All of the nights I don't remember when you're around me
I've been dancing on top of cars and stumbling out of bars
I follow you through the dark, can't get enough
You're the medicine and the pain, the tattoo inside my brain
And baby you know it's obvious
I'm a sucker for you
Said a word and I'll go anywhere blindly
I'm a sucker for you, yeah
Any road you take you know that you'll find me
I'm a sucker for all the subliminal things
No one knows about you, about you, about you, about you
And I'm making my typical me, make my typical move
It is true, I'm a sucker for you
I've been dancing on top of cars and stumbling out of bars
I follow you through the dark, can't get enough
You're the medicine and the pain, the tattoo inside my brain
And baby you know it's obvious
I'm a sucker for you, yeah
Said a word and I'll go anywhere blindly
Any road you take you know that you'll find me
I'm a sucker for all the subliminal things
No one knows about you, about you, about you, about you
And I'm making my typical me, make my typical move
It is true, I'm a sucker for you
I'm a sucker for you
I've never been this way before
I got this feeling inside my bones
It goes electric wavy when I turn it on
All through my city, all through my home
We're flying up, no ceiling when we in our zone
I got that sunshine in my pocket
Got that good soul in my feet
I feel that hot blood in my body
And it drops, ooh
I can't take my eyes off of it
Moving so phenomenally
You're more like the way we rock it
So don't stop
Under the lights when everything goes
Nowhere to hide when I'm getting you close
When we move, well, you already know
So just imagine
Nothing I can see but you
When you dance, dance, dance
I feel a good, good creeping up on you
So just dance, dance, dance
Come on
All those things I shouldn't do
But you dance, dance, dance
There ain't nobody leaving soon
So keep dancing
I can't stop the feeling
So just dance, dance, dance
Come on
Ooh, it's something magical
It's in the air, it's in my blood
It's rushing on
I don't need no reason
Don't need control
I fly so high, no ceiling when I'm in my zone
Cause I got that sunshine in my pocket
Got that good soul in my feet
I feel that hot blood in my body
When it drops, ooh
I can't take my eyes off of it
Moving so phenomenally
You're more like the way we rock it
So don't stop
Under the lights when everything goes
Nowhere to hide when I'm getting you close
When we move, well, you already know
So just imagine
Nothing I can see but you
When you dance, dance, dance
Feels so good creeping up on you
So just dance, dance, dance
Come on
All those things I shouldn't do
But you dance, dance, dance
There ain't nobody leaving soon
So keep dancing
I can't stop the feeling
So just dance, dance, dance
So keep dancing
I can't stop the
I can't stop the feeling
Nothing I can see but you
When you dance, dance, dance
Feels so good creeping up on you
So just dance, dance, dance
Come on
All those things I shouldn't do
But you dance, dance, dance
There ain't nobody leaving soon
So keep dancing
Everybody say
I can't stop the feeling in my body
I can't stop the feeling
Nothing I can see but you
When you dance, dance, dance
I can't stop the feeling in my body
Break it down
Got this feeling in my body
Can't stop the feeling
Come on
I didn't ask for a free ride
I only asked you to show me a real good time
I never asked for the rainbow
But at least I showed up
You showed me the thing that I'm
It's coming down on me
Water like misery
I'm ready rain on me
I might be drunk but at least I'm alive
Rain on me, rain, rain
Rain on me
Living in a world where no one's innocent
Oh but at least we tried
Gotta live my truth, not keep it bottled in
So I don't lose my man
I can feel it on my skin
It's coming down on me
Skin drops on my face
Water like misery
Better wash away my sins
It's coming down on me
Better wash away
I might not be drunk but at least I'm alive
Rain on me, rain, rain
Rain on me
Hands up to the sky
I'll be your galaxy
I'm about to fly
Rain on me, tsunami
Hands up to the sky
I'll be your galaxy
I'm about to fly
Rain on me
I might not be drunk but at least I'm alive
Rain on me, rain, rain
Rain on me
I might not be drunk but at least I'm alive
Rain on me, rain, rain
Rain on me
I hear the thunder coming down
Won't you rain on me
Rain on me
I hear the thunder coming down
Won't you rain on me
Rain on me
Yeah
You are my fire
The one desire
Believe when I say
I want it that way
But we are two worlds apart
Can't reach to your heart
When you say
That I want it that way
Tell me why
Ain't nothing but a thought today
Ain't nothing but a mistake
Tell me why
I never wanna hear you say
I want it that way
In my mind
You're my fire
The one desire
Yes I know
It's too late
But I want it that way
Tell me why
Ain't nothing but a thought today
Ain't nothing but a mistake
Tell me why
I never wanna hear you say
I want it that way
Now I can see that we've fallen apart
From the way that it used to be
Yeah
No matter the distance
I want you to know
That deep down inside of me
You are my fire
The one desire
You are
Don't wanna hear you say
Ain't nothing but a thought today
Ain't nothing but a mistake
I never wanna hear you say
I want it that way
Tell me why
Ain't nothing but a thought today
Ain't nothing but a mistake
Tell me why
I never wanna hear you say
I want it that way
Tell me why
Ain't nothing but a thought today
Ain't nothing but a mistake
Tell me why
I never wanna hear you say
I want it that way
Cause I want it that way
Alabama, Arkansas
I do love my mom and pop
Not the way that I do love you
Well holy moly nearby
You're the apple of my eye
Girl I've never loved one like you
Man oh man you're my best friend
I scream it too
There's nothing that
There ain't nothing that I need
Well hot and heavy
Pumpkin pie
Chocolate candy
Jesus Christ
There ain't nothing that pleases me more than you
Oh, let me come home
Home is wherever I'm with you
La, la, la, take me home
Baby I'm coming home
I'll follow you into the park
Through the jungle, through the dark
Girl I've never loved one like you
Marching boats and waterfalls
Alleyways and payphone calls
I've been everywhere with you
That's true
Laughing till we think we're done
Been put on the summer line
And it really is sweeter than with you
And in the streets you're running free
Like it's only you and me
Cheering if you're sunk in the sea
Oh, let me come home
Home is wherever I'm with you
Home, home, home
La, la, la, take me home
Baby I'm coming home
Jay
Alexander
Do you remember that day you fell out of my window?
I sure do, you came jumping out after me
Well, you fell out of the concrete and nearly broke your ass
And you were bleeding all over the place
And I rushed you out to the hospital, do you remember that?
Yes, I do
Well, there's something I never told you about that night
What did you tell me?
While you were sitting in the back seat smoking a cigarette
You thought it was gonna be your last
I was falling deep, deep in love with you
And I never told you till last night
Oh, let me come home
Home is wherever I'm with you
Home, let me come home
Home, yes I am home
Home is when I'm alone with you
Home, let me come home
Home is wherever I'm with you
What I want you got, it might be hard to handle
Like a flame that burns a candle, a candle feeds the flame
What I got, full stop, thoughts and dreams that scatter
When you pull them all together, and I can't explain
Oh yeah, well well you, you make my dreams come true
You, you, you, you, you, you
Well well well you, oh yeah, you make my dreams come true
You, you, well yeah, you
On a night when the band, we become a screamer
When the medicine with the dreamer, I can laugh it in the face
Twist and shout my way out, and wrap yourself around me
Cause I ain't the way you found me, and I'll never be the same
Oh yeah, well cause you, you make my dreams come true
You, you, well yeah, you
Well well well you, you make my dreams come true
You, you, you, you, you, you
Now listen to this
Ow!
I'm down on my daydreams, oh that sleepwalk should be over by now
Oh no, oh you, yeah yeah, you make my dreams come true
Oh yeah, I'm waiting for, waiting for you, girl
Oh yeah, you make my dreams come true
I'm waiting for, waiting for you, girl
Oh, you make my dreams come true
Oh, you, oh, you-u-u Ooh
I've been waiting for, waiting for,
waiting for, waiting for, waiting for,
You make my dreams
Ooh
I've been waiting for you, girl
You make my dreams
You, you, you
Oh, what a night
Late December back in sixty-three
What a very special time for me
As I remember, what a night
Oh, what a night
You know I didn't even know her name
But I was never gonna be the same
What a lady, what a night
Oh, I
I got a funny feeling when she walked
In the room with mine
As I recall it ended much too soon
Oh, what a night
Hypnotizing, mesmerizing me
She was everything I dreamed she'd be
Sweet surrender, what a night
I felt a rush like a whirling form of thunder
Screaming my head around and digging my body under
What a night
Oh, I
I got a funny feeling when she walked
In the room with mine
As I recall it ended much too soon
Oh, what a night
Boy, it takes a lot to see the light
Seemed so wrong, but now it seems so right
What a lady, what a night
Oh, I
I felt a rush like a whirling form of thunder
Screaming my head around and digging my body under
What a night
Her eyes, her eyes
Make the stars look like they're not shining
Her hair, her hair
Falls perfectly without her trying
She's so beautiful
And I tell her every day
Yeah, I know, I know
When I compliment her she won't believe me
And it's so, it's so
Sad to think that she don't see what I see
But every time she asks me do I look okay
I say
When I see your face
There's not a thing that I would change
Cause you're amazing
Also, also if you are doing the baptizing
You should also be in here
If you're being baptized or doing the baptizing
Thank you
The whole world stops and stares for a while
Cause girl, you're amazing
Just the way you are
Her lips, her lips
I could kiss them all day if she'd let me
Her laugh, her laugh
She hates but I think it's so sexy
She's so beautiful
And I tell her every day
Oh, you know, you know, you know
I never ask you to change
If perfect's what you're searching for
Then just stay the same
So, don't even bother asking if you look okay
You know I'll say
When I see your face
There's not a thing that I would change
Cause you're amazing
Just the way you are
And when you smile
The whole world stops and stares for a while
Cause girl, you're amazing
Just the way you are
The way you are
Girl, you're amazing
Just the way you are
When I see your face
There's not a thing that I would change
Cause you're amazing
Just the way you are
And when you smile
The whole world stops and stares for a while
Cause girl, you're amazing
Just the way you are
Yeah
Young man
There's no need to feel down
I said young man
Hit yourself off the ground
Cause you're in a new town
There's no need to be unhappy
Young man
There's a place you can go
I said young man
When you're short on your dough
You can stay there
And I'm sure you will find many ways
To have a good time
It's fun to stay at the
YMCA
They have everything
For young men to enjoy
And you can hang out all the boy
It's fun to stay at the
YMCA
You can get yourself clean
You can have a good meal
You can do whatever you feel
Young man
Are you listening to me?
I said young man
What do you wanna be?
You can make brilliant dreams
But you've got to know
This one thing
Young man
Does it all by himself
I said young man
Put your pride on the shelf
And just go there
To the YMCA
I'm sure they can help you today
It's fun to stay at the
YMCA
They have everything
For young men to enjoy
And you can hang out all the boy
It's fun to stay at the
YMCA
You can get yourself clean
You can have a good meal
You can do whatever you feel
Young man
I was once in your shoes
I said I was
Down and out with the blues
I felt young man
Said if I were alive
I felt the whole world
Was so tired last week
Someone came up to me
And said young man
Take a walk up the street
It's a place there
Called the YMCA
They can stop you
Back on your way
It's fun to stay at the
YMCA
They have everything
For young men to enjoy
And you can have one with all the boys
YMCA
It's fun to stay at the
Young man, young man
There's no need to feel down
Get yourself off the ground
YMCA
It's fun to stay at the
Young man, young man
Are you listening to me?
What did you wanna be?
YMCA
You'll find it at the
Young man, young man
Love it all by itself
Put your pride on the shelf
YMCA
And just go to the
Young man, young man
I was once in your shoes
I wish I was blue
YMCA
I used to think maybe you loved me
Now baby I'm sure
And I just can't wait till the day
When you knock on my door
Now every time I go for the mailbox
Gotta hold myself down
Cause I just can't wait till you write me
Or call me around
Now I'm walking on sunshine
I'm walking on sunshine
And I feel good
Hey!
I used to think maybe you loved me
Now I know that it's true
And I don't wanna spend my whole life
Just waiting for you
Now I don't want you back for the weekend
Not back for a day
No, no, no
And baby I just want you back
And I want you to stay
Oh yeah
I'm walking on sunshine
And I feel good
All right now
Oh yeah
And I feel good
Walking on sunshine
I feel alive, I feel alive
I feel alive in Trinity
I'm on sunshine, baby
I'm walking on sunshine
And I feel good
All right now
Oh yeah
And I feel good
Hey everybody, I got a small announcement regarding baptisms.
So there's a camera over here by the food tables
and I'm trying to shoot a line from the camera
through the gate to where Brett's gonna be doing the baptism.
So if you guys, when that starts, please help me keep that path open
so if you got kids, just hold on to them.
Whatever, anyways, that's the plan. Thanks.
I promise that you'll never find another like me
I know that I'm a handful, baby
I know I never think before I jump
And you're the kind of guy the ladies want
And there's a lot of cool shit out there
I know that I'm a psycho on the phone
I never leave well enough alone
And trouble's gonna follow where I go
And there's a lot of cool shit out there
But one of these things is not like the others
Like a rainbow with all of the colors
Maybe though when it comes to a lover
I promise that you'll never find another like me
I'm the only one of me
Baby, that's the fun of me
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh
You're the only one of you
Baby, that's the fun of you
And I promise that nobody's gonna love you like me
I know I tend to make it about me
I know you never get just what you see
But I will never fall you, baby
And there's a lot of cool shit out there
And when we had that fight out in the rain
You ran after me and called my name
I never wanna see you walk away
And there's a lot of cool shit out there
Cause one of these things is not like the others
Living in winter, I am your summer
Maybe though when it comes to a lover
I promise that you'll never find another like me
I'm the only one of me
Let me keep you company
You're the only one of you
Baby, that's the fun of you
And I promise that nobody's gonna love you like me
Girl, there ain't no I in T
But you know there is a me
Strike the band up, one, two, three
I promise that you'll never find another like me
Girl, there ain't no I in T
But you know there is a me
And you can't spell awesome without me
I promise that you'll never find another like me
I'm the only one of me
Baby, that's the fun of me
You're the only one of you
Baby, that's the fun of you
And I promise that nobody's gonna love you like me
Girl, there ain't no I in T
But you know there is a me
I'm the only one of me
Baby, that's the fun of me
Strike the band up, one, two, three
You can't spell awesome without me
You're the only one of you
Baby, that's the fun of you
And I promise that nobody's gonna love you like me
You're the only one of you
You know I'm bad at communication
It's the hardest thing for me to do
And it's it, it's the most important part
That relationships have gone through
And I gave it all away
Just so I could say that to you
Well, I know, I know, I know, I know
That you're gonna be okay anyway
You know there's no lack of reason
For the way you turned out to be
I didn't go and try to change my mind
Not intentionally
I know it's hard to hear me say it
But I can't bear to say it
I just know, I know, I know, I know
That you're gonna be okay anyway
Always keep your heart locked tight
Don't let your mind read that
Oh, but I just couldn't take it
To try to, to fake it
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
It felt bad
It felt right
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
It felt bad
It felt right
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
Now here's your imagination
You get what you wanted to be
Because I'm sorry I did what I did
But it came naturally
And I gave it all away
Just so I could say that
Well, I know, I know, I know, I know
That you're gonna be okay anyway
When I tried to keep myself together
After all the opportunities
I tried to stay true to you
And I tried to do what you wanted from me
And I gave it all away
Just to hear you say that
Well, I know, I know, I know, I know
That you're gonna be okay anyway
Always keep your heart locked tight
Don't let your mind rebound
Oh, but I just couldn't take it
To try to, to fake it
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
It felt bad
It felt right
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
It felt bad
It felt right
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
Always keep your heart locked tight
Don't let your mind rebound
Oh, but I just couldn't take it
To try to, to fake it
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
But I just couldn't take it
To try to, to fake it
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
It felt bad
It felt right
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
It felt bad
It felt right
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
Yeah
It felt right
But I fumbled and when I came down to the wire
To your left, my right
If y'all want to fill in a little bit over here
You can stay in the shade
We will want to leave this space right here at the entryway to the gate open
So that folks online can see us
Well again, thank you all for being here tonight
It's just such a special, such a special evening
I mean you're really at like literally the first baptism service of the table
Yeah, give it up
It's beautiful, beautiful
And at the end of the day though, this really isn't so much about us as an institution or something
This really is about Jesus and about what Christ is doing in the lives, not just of all of you
But specifically some really wonderful people who are taking just a beautiful step tonight
To just commit themselves to Christ in a new way
So I'm just so grateful for those who have been meeting with me now for the last few weeks
We've had a number of baptism classes where we were able to kind of talk through some of what baptism means
And we've also had some one-off conversations for those who weren't able to attend that
We were able to chat with them
So these folks have given thought and prayer to this
And for the younger people, they've processed it with their parents
And this isn't like a flippant decision for anyone
I've really, I've honestly had some really amazing heartfelt conversations with folks
As they're like wrestling with this step
And so I'm just, I'm really proud
I'm really, really proud of every person that's stepping up to be baptized today
So I won't keep you all long, but I did want to kind of frame tonight
With a passage from Matthew chapter 28, verses 19 through 20
It's the very end of the book of Matthew
And these are some of Jesus' final words to his disciples before his ascension
And he said,
And I think such a beautiful part of that is the
And teaching them to obey everything I have commanded you
This whole service and really what the table is about as a community
We're not just interested in making converts
Churning out converts to say, oh yes, okay, I want to go to heaven!
And it's sort of like, well, that's fine
But at the end of the day, this isn't just about trying to avoid the bad place or something
This is about committing to a life of love and faithfulness in the way of Jesus
And I just, man, there can be so much bad religion in the world
And I think any religion that's being driven by fear
Fear of some terrible image of God
Or fear of, oh my gosh, God's going to hurt me unless I get baptized
That's just not the spirit of Jesus
Like we've been talking about a message a week or two ago
It was on 1 John chapter 4, which says,
And when I think of baptism, I think of it just as a moment
Of choosing the one who is perfect love
And committing yourself to walk in that way
Like that's what discipleship is
It's falling in love with the one who is himself love
And then being saturated by that and then spreading it to others
So as folks come down and as each one is baptized
That's the path, that's what they're committing to
It's discipleship, it's a commitment to live like Jesus
Which is to say, to live a life of love in every aspect
So, alright, let me pray and then we'll get started
Lord Jesus, we just thank you for tonight
And I just lift up all of my friends who are taking this step today
And I pray peace over them
I pray the fullness of your Holy Spirit over them
God, as they leave that kind of false self behind
God, all the addictions, the struggles, the sins
The things that have kind of torn down their life
God, I pray that they would step away from that
And they would walk in your new life
That it would be powerful and effective for them, God
Yeah, so we welcome you here
We acknowledge your presence
And I pray that this would be just a holy moment
It's in the life-changing name of Jesus that I pray, Amen
Alright, I think we're going to have Eve
Tilford come forward, so come on girl
And her mom wanted to say a few words
I have an in with the pastor
And I told him, well I asked Eve first
When we were talking about getting baptized
There's this one story, I just have to share this
Somewhere around the age of 3 or 4, I don't remember
But we were going to the grocery store
To get a gift for her aunt
And she asked, can we get something for me while we're there
And I said, no, this trip is not about you, this trip is about your aunt
And we're buying something for her today, it's not about you today
And she didn't like that
She's always been very good at expressing her feelings
And she was kind of throwing her own little fit
And I said, I'm going to go upstairs and get my shoes and then we're leaving
And I want you to change your attitude
And she yelled up the stairs behind me, I don't love my aunt, I don't love Jesus
And I'm never getting baptized
And here we are today
And she told me she wanted to get baptized
I was like, you do realize that means you're going back on your commitment of a 4 year old
And she's comfortable with that now
I did ask her if I could share that story
I can't help but think of that in this moment
So Eve, could you go ahead and share why you want to be baptized today?
Because lately God has been speaking to me
And I feel like it's the right time
And Eve, do you commit your whole life to Jesus?
And are you committed to live the life of love that he's calling you to live?
Yes I do
Great
Eve, I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Who's next?
Marissa
Marissa, can you share with us why you want to be baptized today?
I've prepared a statement just so I can stay concisely on point and not ramble
For those of you who don't know, I was raised Roman Catholic
Which means I was baptized as an infant
For those of you who don't know, I'm also gay
My faith journey has swung to both ends of the spectrum
From faithful to atheist and everywhere in between
I've done a great deal of work over the past few years
And while I had an opportunity to be baptized in my former church
Perhaps because I needed more time to do more work
I know beyond a shadow of a doubt that I'm fully committed to continue on this journey
That I'll continue to fail, but continue to try
That I want my life and works to reflect Christ perfectly through my human imperfection
I want my identity to be cemented in Christ and Christian community before all else
My baptism today is a sign of my heartfelt commitment to this
As a gay woman, I carry significant hurt and judgment
And exclusion, I'm sorry, I carry significant hurt and damage
From judgment and exclusion from Christians and church in general
I also carry incredible hurt and trauma
From LGBTQ Christians excluding me
And acting anything but Christ-like toward me
This is a uniquely horrific pain that I expected to carry to my grave
Over the past year and a half, I've slowly come to realize
That my faith and the people within it are a healing balm
That I never could have imagined into existence for myself
My baptism today, in this place, is also a sign of my commitment to this church
And to each of you here with me tonight
Thank you for celebrating and encouraging me
And most of all for loving me unconditionally
And reflecting the love of Christ to and for me
Thank you
And Marissa, do you commit your whole life to Jesus Christ?
And are you committed to living into his life of love for you?
Yes, I do
Marissa, I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Thank you
Alright, Alina
You get to look at everybody
There you go, alright
Alina, can you go ahead and share why you want to be baptized today?
Because I want to start a new and better path with God
She wants to start a new and better path with God
Beautiful
Alright, come on down
Jeff, her dad is going to baptize her
I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Kaitlyn, y'all give her a hand
Can you share with everyone why you want to be baptized today?
I was baptized when I was in middle school
And I really felt that when I did it then
That it was more out of fear, God fearing
And since then I have found
I have found new faith in Christ loving
Instead of Christ fearing
And I really just want to renew that commitment
To a loving and merciful God
Especially with my new church family
Kaitlyn, I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Way to go Kaitlyn
Is it Mariah next?
Come on down
Alright, Mariah, can you share with everyone why you want to be baptized today?
Sure, I'll try to do it without crying
Okay, hi everybody
Can you hear me?
So, much like Kaitlyn, I got baptized very young
I grew up in a church that was very hard, very controlling, and very damaging
And so it took me a long time to get to a place where I felt loved and accepted from God
And I just want to thank everyone that's been here in the table, whether I know you personally or not
It's been really wonderful getting to know all of you
Thank you, Brett
This has been so much fun just to get to know the love of God
And I can't wait for more
Awesome
It's deep
Swim back, swim back
Mariah, do you commit your whole life to the Lord Jesus Christ and to live a life of love?
Absolutely
Oh, gosh
I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Way to go
Kaylee, girl
And Kaylee, and this is her dad, Daryl, who will be doing the baptizing
So, Kaylee, can you go ahead and share with everyone why you want to be baptized today?
This past year, I've been leaning towards God more than ever, and I feel like it's just the next step forward
Awesome, alright
And Kaylee, do you commit your whole life to the Lord Jesus Christ, and are you committed to live a life of love?
Yes
Alright
Kaylee, I baptize you in the name of the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Woo!
There's a crayon
Adam, come on
Give it up
Woo!
That's great
Adam
So, my friend, can you go ahead and share with everyone why you want to be baptized today?
Um, before I came to the table, I had a hatred for God, I felt alone, and I just hated everything and everything about Christians
And after I came here, I just felt so much love and acceptance, and I've never been so proud of myself and you guys
And I just love you all so much, and just thank you for accepting me, and yeah
Beautiful
And Adam, are you committed to give your whole life to the Lord Jesus Christ, and to live into his way of love?
Yes
Thank you
And Adam, I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Woo!
Alright, y'all give it up for Graham
Alright, Graham, can you share with everyone why you want to be baptized today?
Um, it was a few years ago, we went, I felt like I needed to go back to church, and we went to a church, and we really liked it there
But then one day we saw Brett talking, and we're like, who is this guy? He's awesome, and we kind of forgot about him
And then we heard that he was leaving, so we went and found his church, and life has been so good since we've met Brett
And been to the table, and just been with all of you
And um, I just really want to live like Jesus, like as for my wife, for my kids, for my school, my community, and that's why I'm doing it
Awesome
So Graham, are you committed to give your whole life to Jesus Christ, and to live a life of love?
I do
Yeah
Graham, I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Alright, can you share with everyone why you want to be baptized today?
So growing up, can you all hear me? Okay
So growing up, I wasn't really consistent going to church, like I had a relationship with God, but it wasn't a strong and consistent one like I have now
And I feel like I've had this strong and consistent relationship, really back to New Hope Lucas, and then continuing on through the table
So I just feel so ready to do this, and yeah
And Miranda, are you ready to commit your whole life to Jesus Christ, and to devote yourself to his path of love?
Yes
Alright, Miranda, I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Now you get to hold. Oh yeah, thumb. Here
Tyler, can you share with everyone why you want to be baptized today?
Well, I was baptized. Can you hear me? I can't hear myself over here, but okay
I was baptized probably in about the third grade, after VBS, and it was just one of those things
All the kids were doing it, so I wanted to do it too, right?
I didn't realize what it meant at that time. I figured it out later in life, and then I left the church
I was raised Baptist. I found my way back though, thanks to the Adams, and thanks to Brett
And I couldn't imagine a better church family to recommit my life with, as I start my new family
Tyler, do you commit your whole life to Jesus Christ, and are you devoted to his path of love?
Yes
Tyler, I baptize you in the name of the Father, and the Son, and the Holy Spirit
Alright. Is that everyone? Okay. Oh, that was beautiful. Can we give them one more round of applause?
And let me pray. Jesus, we just seal this time and these commitments, God
By just acknowledging your presence. And Jesus, I pray for every person that made this commitment today
That they would live that life of love, that they would follow you closely
And that even as they still know they have so much to learn, God, but that you would just continue to take them deeper
God, I pray this next year for them is one of just exponential growth
And just that their lives would be saturated in your love
That they would start to live with a sense of your presence, and that they would know your faithful love for them
So we love them, we're committed to them as a church family
God, help us to be faithful, help us to speak the truth in love
To be that place of encouragement and grace and the hard word, but also the uplifting word
God, help us to be that kind of church community
We love you Lord, we thank you for your goodness and faithfulness in this last year and a half
You've been so good to us. In Christ's precious name I pray. Amen
Amen
Yes
Well, I encourage you to, if you get a chance, to say congratulations, I love you
You know, all the things to some of the folks that got baptized
Let's make sure that they feel loved on and seen
And you are welcome to kind of continue to hang out
We'll have the bounce house here, everything's kind of here
And yeah, you're welcome to just chill
I've heard we might try to get a volleyball game going, so if anyone's interested, you know
And, yes, Karen?
Oh yes, and of course, thank you, a huge thank you to
I mean, there's been a number of volunteers that have helped, but specifically Miranda Phillips
Brandy Adams gave a lot of time the last few weeks to prep all this and bring it together
So, thank you to them, and a number of you also that showed up early to help us get prepped and set up
So, alright, I think that's everything
So, thank you all again for coming, feel free to hang out
And we love you all lots
Grace and peace
I work every day of my life
I work till I ache my bones
At the end, at the end of the day
I take home my hard-earned pay
Oh, the world is right
But I'll find it's not
Time to go
Till the tears run down from my eyes
All to Jesus I surrender
All to Him I freely give
I will ever love and trust Him
In His presence daily live
I surrender all
All to Thee my blessed Savior
All to Jesus I surrender
Make me Savior holy Thine
And let me feel Your Holy Spirit
And truly know that Thou art mine
I surrender all
All to Thee my blessed Savior
All to Jesus I surrender
Humbly at His feet I bow
And worldly pleasures all forsaken
Take me Jesus, take me now
I surrender all
All to Thee my blessed Savior